[Music
] artificial intelligence is at the heart
of thales' digital transformation
it is one of the four
technological pillars on which the group
bases this transformation
the other three being the treatment of
animals civ the internet of things
connectivity and
cybersecurity through its fields of activity, which
cover aeronautics, space,
rail transport, security
and defense, thales operates in the world
of critical systems,
a world that is highly regulated where
the stakes of the decisions taken and the
actions taken can  be vital this is
why the nature of the
artificial intelligence technologies developed
or used by thales must meet the
requirements of a trusted ia these
requirements are validity explain it
empowered security and
responsibility united a valid it is a  ai
that has been proven to do
what they expected no more and no
less an inexplicable it is an ai that
provides  the justifications of its
recommendations decision if necessary in
real time in a language
understandable by humans and in a
way adapted to the
context  is unia compliant with ethical principles
including sustainability and
preservation of the planet
as well as legal and regulatory frameworks in
order to develop and
guarantee our customers this
trusted artificial intelligence
it is necessary to put in place a
real ingenious and  building the
appropriate framework to do this is
the subject of the great national challenge on ai, in
particular through its
confidence points program it is a
partnership approach with an
industrial vocation whose objective is to
build and produce  together the
methods tools and processes to
design develop validate see
certify deploy and maintain in
operating condition  ion of
artificial intel-based systems
thales has been committed to this
program since its youth in a
proactive way alongside
industrial and academic partners who share
common values and ambition in the field
of trusted AI so
let's raise this in  challenge but let's build
together a future of trust
[Music]